je suis né
et j'ai grandi dans un pays en guerre à
l'âge de 4 ans pendant que les bons de
tomber mon père m'occuper à faire ça
c'était mon carnet de coloriage mon
grand père et son frère avaient fondé
une entreprise de décoration
il crée des salons orientaux en
boiseries peintes
mon père a travaillé avec eux avant de
devenir artiste peintre mon nom tarasy
vient du mot arabe donne aux in qui veut
dire ce qui brode mes ancêtres étaient
brodeur ma ligne et manas naturellement
transmis le langage secret des lignes et
des couleurs quand on grandit dans le
chaos et la violence avec des parents
qui pensent que la guerre va durer
quelques jours et qu'elle dure quinze
ans on ne sait pas que ce n'est pas
normal pour quitter la guerre le chaos
la confusion j'ai quitté mon pays le
liban et je suis venu vivre en france
installé à paris depuis plusieurs années
j'étais au temps tourmentés canton de
guer j'ai alors entrepris une quête de
guérison
j'ai multiplié les stages de
développement personnel de thérapie et
de théâtre jusqu'au jour où j'ai fait un
stage sur le vêtement et là j'ai basculé
dans mon corps avant j'allais dans les
magasins j'ai acheté ce qui me tombait
sous la main des coups de coeur sans
jamais vraiment être satisfaite je ne
savais pas ce que je cherchais
exactement avant je portais des
vêtements qui ne représentaient pas qui
je suis j'avais le sentiment d'être
déguisé selon les occasions pour un
rendez vous professionnel je portais ma
veste noire cintrée pour paraître
crédible mais je me sentais engoncé est
embarrassé d'afficher une autorité qui
ce n'était pas la mienne pour un mariage
je cherchais la robe que j'avais vu
porter sur mon actrice préférée dans un
film mais ça ne marcherait jamais tout à
fait je me sentais pas très à l'aise
fausse maladroite
étais je portais les robes vaporeuses
légère féminine et puis la saharienne au
bord de la plage pour paraître aussi
sexy que les mannequins dans les
magazines mais j'avais l'air d'un sac
est beaucoup plus grosse que ce que
j'étais en réalité et puis le déclic je
comprend finalement comment m'habiller
comment m'habiller vrai si je suis ici
ce n'est pas pour vous parler de la
coquetterie du vêtement mais pour vous
parler de conscience du corps
pourquoi c'est important d'avoir
conscience de son corps
et bien parce qu'à l'intérieur se
trouvent vos ressentis vos émotions tout
ce qui fonde votre être votre
échafaudages pour construire votre vie
donc quand vous avez conscience de votre
corps vous avez accès à ça vous pouvez
construire votre vie à partir de vous
plutôt qu'à partir des attentes
extérieur donc écoutez bien je vais vous
emmener en voyage à l'intérieur de votre
corps pour que vous aussi vous puissiez
vous aviez vrai votre corps à trois
composantes qui les fondent la carnation
les mouvements et l' architecture votre
corps émet une lumière dorée ou argentée
vous avez une lumière dorée quand ce
sont les artères qui colore votre peau
lui donnant un fonds rougeâtre vous êtes
soit de carnation printemps c'est le
moment où le soleil augmente on a plus
de lumière les couleurs gagnant en
transparence en pétillance on va
retrouver aussi cette transparence dans
la peau de ces personnes printemps un
regard qui va chercher à l'extérieur
comme la lumière du printemps et missy
20 soit vous êtes de carnation automne
c'est le moment où la lumière décline
les couleurs deviennent plus profonde
plus épaisse et on verra que la peau de
ces personnes là aussi est plus épaisse
il ya plus de présence dans le regard
des personnes qui sont cul ce temps le
don de soi dans la générosité
donc elles vont attirer à elle comme la
lumière de l'automne qui descend à
l'intérieur vous êtes de carnation
argenté quand son
les veines qui colore votre peau lui
donnant un fond bleuté plus froid alors
vous êtes soit de carnation était alors
c'est le moment où le soleil est à son
zénith
la lumière est à son maximum et donc
elle voit la nature d'un voile blanc ce
qui fait qu'on ne voit pas trop de
contrastes il ya énormément de subtilité
dans les couleurs qui deviennent
beaucoup plus douce poudre et on va
retrouver ce manque de contraste chez
les personnes de la carnation été et
cette douceur ce léger voile blanc dans
le regard
soit vous avez la carnation hiver c'est
le moment où la lumière est à son
minimum donc le contraste augmente on ne
voit plus de détails on voit uniquement
les extrêmes le blanc le noir le glacis
l'intense on va retrouver cette
intensité chez les gens de cette
carnation on ne verra pas de détails
mais uniquement des très franc qui donne
un air très typés saviez vous que
lorsque vous portez des couleurs qui
sont trop éloignés de la lumière de
votre corps cela peut vous griser le
visage vous donner un air fatigué vous
vieillir mais quand vous portez des
couleurs qui reprennent la lumière de
votre corps ça vous unifie visuellement
mais ça vous donne aussi la sensation
d'être unifiées moi quand j'ai découvert
mes couleurs je n'étais pas très
surprise par contre ça m'a permis de
comprendre pourquoi il y avait certaines
couleurs que je ne portais que très
rarement et j'ai pu vraiment mettre
l'histoire que je me racontais derrière
qui n'était pas moi chez l'embryon avant
que la peau et le système nerveux ne se
développe en deux organes séparés ils
forment un seul et même feuillet qui
s'appelle l'hecto derme
ce n'est que plus tard dans le
développement de l'embryon que cette
ectothermes va se séparer en deux
organes qui sont d'une part la peau qui
a un rôle de protection et d'autre part
le système nerveux qui fonde votre
sensibilité
donc tout ce que vous posez sur votre
corps aj jusque dans votre système
nerveux
certaines textures de matières vont vous
exciter désagréablement alors que
d'autres ont vous apaiser et vous
redressez jusqu à agir
sur votre bien-être sur votre
respiration et votre humeur nous avons
tous une manière de bouger une texture
de corps qui rappelle l'un des quatre
éléments de la nature l'air l'eau la
terre et le feu
si votre corps est léger et aérien comme
l'air vous avez besoin de bouger
d'ouvrir les fenêtres de respirer vous
êtes impatients plutôt rapide
choisissez des matières qui n'ont pas de
poids qui vont vraiment épousé vos
mouvements et leur donner la liberté
si votre corps est relâché et souple
comme l'eau alors vous êtes quelqu'un de
plutôt lent qui a besoin de temps pour
réagir
choisissez des matières fluides lourdes
épaisse onctueuse qui vont épouser les
formes de votre corps et vous aider à
ralentir pour rentrer dans votre rythme
si vous êtes plutôt comme la terre poser
danse vous parlait pas beaucoup mais
vous absorbez énormément de l'extérieur
on a envie de se confier à vous
choisissez des matières épaisses
enveloppante confortable qui font pas de
pili mais qui sont néanmoins souple et
si votre corps a été structurée et
intense comme le feu vous allez alors
avoir besoin de maintien avec des
vêtements qui vous contiennent qui sont
ajustés qui vont vraiment vous contenir
dans l'intensité de vos gestes dans les
contrastes que vous allez avoir dans
votre manière d'être
moi quand j'ai découvert mes matières au
ça a été une réelle libération parce que
j'ai compris pourquoi y avait des
vêtements que j'avais usé et d'autres
dans lesquels je me sentais déguisée que
j'avais besoin d'enlever juste après mon
rendez vous ces matières hautmont
vraiment aidé à être dans ma légitimité
par rapport à mon hypersensibilité et au
fait que très souvent je me liquéfie con
quand je suis en stress et donc je
prends soin vraiment de cette
hypersensibilité et je m'affiche tels
que je suis dès le départ ce qui fait
que je n'ai plus rien à perdre
on a aussi larchitecture du corps qui
étaient importantes pour les coupes de
vêtements alors vous êtes ligne si votre
colonne vertébrale dirige le corps donc
qu'est ce qui se passe quand c'est la
colonne vertébrale qui dirige le corps
vous êtes là vraiment pour guider les
gens pour voir loin
eh bien vous avez besoin de vêtements de
coupe droite qui va retracer l'unité du
corps si vous êtes plutôt de type
losange on voit les articulations chez
vous en premier dont quelque chose de
très anguleux des très mobiles donc les
losanges c'est des gens vraiment qui
sont là pour créer des liens et donc ils
vont avoir besoin de vêtements bas qui
retrace ses lignes de force qui prolonge
ses lignes en diagonale en croisés qui
vont mettre en valeur ses articulations
pour que la personne puisse vraiment
être dans sa mission de relier les idées
et les gens entre elles si vous êtes de
type cercle alors c'est le plan la chair
qui se voit en premier comme chez moi et
donc ce qui va falloir sait mettre en
valeur seront en mettant en valeur vos
formes les gens cercle voilà qu'est ce
qui se passe quand on est vraiment dans
ce mouvement qui prédomine dans la vie
on va fédérer énormément de monde autour
de soi c'est respecter votre nature
corporelle et énergétiques s'habiller
vrai c'est respecter votre lumière vos
mouvements et votre architecture ainsi
votre garde-robe devient indémodable
parce que vous partez de votre corps et
non pas des courants de mode savez
pourquoi la mode nous fascine parce
qu'elle représente la connexion à la
nouveauté mais on a oublié la connexion
la réelle connexion qui est la connexion
à ça et ça a été reléguée à un plan de
superficialité sur la surface des
magazines et du papier glacé le vêtement
bon vêtement m'a permis de me
reconnecter à moi à ma vie et donc à
faire le deuil de tout ce que je n'étais
pas à renoncer à porter les habits des
autres ça ainsi libérer toute mon
énergie au service de ma vie
et aujourd'hui je n'ai plus envie de
changer mon corps
je laime tel qu'il est je ressens une
profonde paix intérieure je peux
m'appuyer sur l'histoire de ma famille
tout en main franche y sent aimé mans
sipan des blessures de mon passé quand
vous vous habillez en partant de votre
corps vous tissez alors une nouvelle
histoire avec lui mais aussi de vous à
votre identité et de vous vous autres
être bien dans ses pompes et danser
vêtements s'est déroulé ce fil invisible
de la rencontre avec soi son corps
l'espace et les autres merci
[Applaudissements]